hey friends i just finished recording
another wonderful episode
with my newfound friend from across the
pond dr harry cliff
ari is a phenomenal communicator of
science and he is infectious in his
enthusiasm for scientific
discovery and communication he wrote a
wonderful book called
how to make an apple pie from scratch
and that's today's episode on into the
impossible talked about many things in
particular the influence that he had
from this one kind of throwaway line
from the cosmos series the famous
popularization of science by
none other than carl sagan the late
husband of past guest andrean
put a link to her episode in the show
notes and father of sasha's saying put a
link to her notes uh her episode from
our uh conversation in 2020
in the show notes as well in this book
is kind of a uh call back what do they
call that uh when you give a shout out
to a
concept of meme what have you in the
popular memosphere and in harry's case
it was this kind of line that was this
line that carl sagan said
if you wish to make
an apple pie from scratch
you must first
invent the universe
so harry goes through the fascinating
history
of the elements the chemical elements
which really leads us on a tour not only
of chemistry but of the particle physics
that underlies chemistry
and furthermore he goes into great
detail on the fascinating discoveries
that he and his colleagues are making at
the large hadron collider you'll find
that incredibly fascinating i did
as well
and he's just so uh so delightful and so
uh so so much fun to talk to i know
you're gonna love this episode please
leave a review we have almost 400
reviews total from around the world just
received one from australia
calling me all sorts of flattering names
so i know it's not one of my brothers or
something like that
um but uh but if you would please leave
a review and you can do that i'll have a
link to the apple podcast feed and you
can leave a review no matter what
podcast
app you're listening on that would be
most helpful
and
i want you to just enjoy the majesty
that is this wonderful book by this
young brilliant writer
from uh from the uk harry cliff dr harry
cliff you'll find links to get to know
him better in his social media feeds
which he's quite prolific at
and
i hope you enjoy this episode
of the into the impossible podcast with
yours truly professor brian keating uc
san diego's arthur c clarke center for
human imagination
come on let's go into the impossible any
sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
open the pod bay doors now
hello everybody today is a big day it is
nearing the end of the year and we are
nearing uh the end of a successful
hopefully some would say successful
completion of another year of pandemic
podcasting
and today we are joined by a marvelous
young scientist from the united kingdom
in the pandemic capital of the world as
he describes it
dr harry cliff how are you today sir
i'm well brian nice to talk to you how
you doing
ah it's wonderful to talk to you uh so
we as you may know on this podcast love
to interview deep thinkers and uh most
of the people that write books uh that
we have come on and authors in physics
and even outside of physics are you know
more theoretically inclined and it's
rare that we get an experimentalist to
come on and i think of yourself and and
i've had on james beacham who's a
collaborator i know uh and uh but very
few other experimental particle
physicists and so i thought it'd be
great to have you on for a long time but
now more than ever because uh for one
thing you recently re released results
and and you led uh some of the release
of these results and we'll talk about
those from the lhcb which alternatively
stands for beauty or bottom or i don't
know brian i like that
but uh but you have this wonderful book
this book is a phenomenal book i'll try
to bring it out and show it to everyone
now this is the us version uh the cover
and uh harry as you may know on this
podcast we always do the thing that
you're forbidden to do which is to judge
books by their covers so i want to ask
you what is the origin of this book's
cover
and title and uh and and the recipe
within you're the first cookbook author
i've ever had on so
help me judge the book by its cover
yeah well i mean so the title is how to
make an apple pie from scratch and
actually the title in a way was one of
the the last things to come to me i've
been thinking about writing this book
for a long time and
you're right that i think a lot of
people who write popular science books
they tend to be more on the theoretical
side because i think they're sort of
they're the people who are thinking more
in this sort of abstract whereas quite
often experimentalists are down you know
with a spanner doing the sort of nuts
and bolts stuff so part of what i wanted
to do with this book was to tell the the
history of
particle physics nuclear physics
astrophysics but from from a sort of uh
experimentalist point of view so there's
a lot more experimentation and so
observation in the book that maybe you
would necessarily get in in other
accounts but in terms of the title it
was one of these things where the book
is essentially about where does mata
come from what are its origins how far
back through the history of the universe
can we go in understanding where it
comes from but i spent a long time
trying to figure out like a kind of
accessible hook for the story and it
actually came to me when i was walking
through my local subway station in south
london and they have this um
white board there where they have a
thought for the day that's written up
and sometimes it's like a kind of trite
thing from a self-help book or or
sometimes they have a sort of they're a
bit more elevated and it's some
philosopher but this particular day was
a quote from carl sagan which he uttered
i think at the start of episode nine of
cosmos this big uh blockbuster 1980s tv
series where there's this slightly
strange scene where he's sitting
actually at the dining table of trinity
college cambridge at the high table this
big paneled medieval hall and there's
this like musical score and his apple
pie is brought out to him and he looks
at the camera with a little twinkle in
his eye and says
if you wish to make
an apple pie from scratch
you must first
invent the universe
thank you very much making is that even
this really mundane object
if you really want to understand it
you've got to go right back through the
history of the universe right
potentially to the big bang and so this
was sort of i thought this is like a a
great way into the story so that the
book is really about the origins of mata
but framed through this kind of idea
that we're looking for the ultimate
recipe for an apple pie and in terms of
the cover then the publishers ran with
that and inevitably an apple ended up on
the on the cover given its association
with newton and gravity and all the rest
of it
yeah it's delightful and uh just to note
i i have had on uh sagan
sasha sagan who is carl's
daughter and uh for her wonderful book
for small creatures such as
we
and uh and her mom carl sagan's uh widow
uh andrew so they were both on and anne
is still involved with the cosmos
project and they've done more i call
them the first family of the universe
and we'll get into some of the the
topics of of your book in just a bit but
just to point out that as a communicator
of science and i aspire to be that as
well
i wonder did you feel nervous you know
is it okay to ask you if you had any
reservations trepidations you're not a
professor yet uh if that's within your
desire uh set of desirables uh i wish
you the best in that um but um but i
wonder you know did you feel a little
bit frightened if that's okay to ask you
i'd like to know taking writing this
book was it was a risk and and i commend
you on taking it and the courage to do
so um did that enter into your thought
process at all at this stage in your
career
uh well
not really and i suppose the reason for
that is i've had a bit of a strange
career so after i finished my graduate
degree i
in all honesty i was sort of in two
minds about whether i was going to stay
in physics and
one of the reasons i stayed in was this
incredible opportunity came up
through cambridge university where i'm
still based and the science museum in
london so i actually spent seven years
post phd
half and half between science
communication and research so i was
doing you know half the week at the
large hadron collider uh the other half
the week at the science museum doing
exhibitions and a lot of so i did a lot
you know communication science has
actually been a big part of my career
professionally and i've sort of learned
a lot in a sort of established
professional institution through doing
that so and that's sort of i think part
of why i think i assume my boss values
me in part at least because of that so
she i was i'm very lucky that my
research group and university be very
supportive in what i want to do because
you're right it's more unusual i think
for someone who's at the sort of
post-doctoral fellow level to be doing
stuff like this and it tends to be
something where people are a bit more
established so
i think where yeah you're right it maybe
would be more of a risk for if you were
a sort of straight researcher but i
think it made a lot of sense for me
because of the particular career i've
carved out and i'm very keen
going forward that this i think you know
communication science is part of what
keeps me excited about the science
itself so it's something i want to carry
on combining so in that sense it made it
made perfect sense
yeah and um you know obviously carl
sagan himself was almost penalized in a
sense for his uh for his public outreach
at least that if you consider you know
lack of membership in the us national
academy of sciences to be a uh you know
a punishment or something to be upset
about uh because you know famously they
considered his you know his conduct as a
as a promoter of science and a
popularizer of science almost
detrimental almost to salesmany uh for
their taste and he was famously not
allowed and even though he established
so many things and and wrote uh very uh
deep and eloquently uh in scientific
journals had a very high citation count
started new journals interdisciplinary
as we'd call them now
and contribute to things like the
planetary society which does actual
research so i think it's a shame
hopefully things like that have changed
although maybe they've gone too far the
other way now we have people that are
just professional communicators that are
the face of science people like past
guest neil degrasse tyson uh not saying
negatively but there's just an
association that he always tries to
deflect that he's actually doing the
signs which he's not um so i think
people like yourself and as i aspire to
be as well um you know are to be you
know somewhat somewhat uh commended at
least for the courage to do it although
in my case i'm a tenured professor uh
although when i wrote my first book my
my department chair said we won't hold
it against you but we're not gonna help
you out we're not gonna
into any anything been any benefit and
this book of yours reminds me of uh
again uh my my audience sometimes hates
it when i name drop but you know
otherwise you're just listening to me
and and uh uh rhapsodize about what i've
done so i want to say it reminds me a
lot of jenna evans book which is a very
personal book her first book how the
universe got its spots and jen is a
wonderful friend and great guest
and i want to you know kind of take you
take the audience through it i never
like to give away the book i want people
to buy it i'll actually give away this
copy that your publisher was so kind to
send i'll actually give this away to
folks in the u.s
because i bought the audiobook instead
as well as
but this book is really kind of a
cry to coor as the french would say
in some better version of that accented
version which is that you know it's it's
one sense an inspirational uh glimpse
into how we know what we know uh but
it's also a call to the future and i
worry you know about the the presence of
hype and maybe we'll start the meat of
the conversation there
um the the presence of hype and science
is somewhat you know looked upon
disfavorably in this book of yours uh
and that we're trying to you know maybe
convince pat you know sell past the sale
in other words saying oh we should do
build the future circular collider
perhaps or something else and we have to
justify it how do you react to people
that say you know what good is this uh
uh you know what good is the lhc what
has it really done for us as a people
yeah i mean it's a it's a valid question
because these projects obviously they
come with huge budgets uh there's
there's several answers to that question
i mean the lhc justifies itself on
number of grounds i mean from a sort of
i think if you ask most scientists the
basic answer is the reason we do
particle physics and cosmology and you
know astrophysics
ultimately is because there's value in
knowing about the world and we want to
understand the world we live in and that
has huge value it's part of what makes
us human that curiosity about you know
the universe around us and i think that
has always got to be the primary
argument for for doing these things
ultimately and the question is does
society value
fundamental knowledge enough to put its
money where its mouth is and build these
big projects but of course that that
isn't the only the only argument because
and actually i suppose it's part of why
i think communication of science is so
important because
fundamental physics you know
astrophysics these are subjects that
they do have spin-offs and applications
but that isn't why we do it right and
and so the real if we're generating this
knowledge
the only reason to do that is if we're
going to share it more widely it
shouldn't just be for our own
entertainment as scientists it's got to
be put out there to the public because
they've paid for it ultimately but in
terms of
um
you know there's there's sort of the
classic arguments one is that you know
if you build something like the lhc
you have this big complicated machine
that when it was being designed the
technology didn't exist to build it and
you have to innovate in terms of say
superconducting magnet technology or
computing technology and then these
developing those technologies for these
publicly funded projects then goes off
and has direct spin out applications in
the world and you know the classic one
that's always trotted out is the world
wide web which was invented at cern by
tim berners-lee as a way of sharing
information on computer networks and
then of course you know has a huge
impact on the on wider society uh like a
very practical example of this i saw a
few years ago where
i went down to visit a superconducting
magnet firm who based in the south of
england and they take a lot of contracts
from particle physics so these are
magnets that are used in the
accelerators to steer beams of particles
around the ring and what they said was
quite interesting which was
usually when they take a contract from
cern or somewhere like it they make a
loss because the amount of money that's
being offered versus the technical
challenge they're being asked to
overcome is is there's a mismatch
basically but the reason they do it is
because
solving these really hard problems they
always learn something which then has an
application elsewhere so they just
developed they've been working with this
new type of superconductor called
niobium tin which is a high field
superconductor that's going to be used
in the future upgrades of the lhc and
the future circular collider if it's
built
and they it's a very difficult material
to work with but they learned to
manipulate this material and then
directly from that project with cern
they were then building uh proton
therapy machines so cancer therapy
machines that previously would have been
far too you've been enormous building
size things they could now build a
compact one that fits in the back of a
van because they'd worked on this some
project so that's just one example but
there are kind of you know you can find
stories like this all over fundamental
physics um
but then of course the other argument
the bigger one i suppose is you never
know
what applications the actual knowledge
you discover may have and
it's you know the higgs i suppose the
higgs boson is the most famous thing to
come out of the lhc so far and it's
even 10 years later really hard to think
you know what use the higgs might be
but you know there's lots of lessons
from history if we go back to say the
1930s when nuclear energy nuclear
physics was being discovered and ernest
rutherford who was you know the world
expert on the nucleus and yeah he
famously said
you know if you're thinking about
getting energy out of the atomic nucleus
you're talking moonshine in other words
this is in like 1932
and he says that you're never going to
get anything out of nuclear energy it's
just a sort of scientific interest sort
of for us scientists and then he's
proven so spectacularly wrong within the
space of you know 13 years so
scientists themselves are often not the
people who are best equipped to
understand what the impact of their own
work is going to be and so those are all
there are all these arguments i think
why we do this stuff and
you know
that's ultimately why i think
for me why we should build the next
accelerator is because there's really
important questions that we need to
answer but that is not you know but also
you're going to get all this other stuff
that comes with it we hope
yeah i always say you know the nobel
prize has a component of it uh given to
higgs
and and
only one other person we can get into
that later perhaps but the higgs has a
component that the uh recipient should
be rewarded in part for
conferring the greatest benefit to
mankind
and obviously the first nobel prize was
to william wrenchen who talked briefly
about in the book and
for the discovery of x-rays and then
that was used to benefit you know
medical diagnostics etc um you know but
i say you know often if the higgs boson
you know properties of it are really
relevant to the benefit or detriment of
your life i i have some good
psychotherapists that i'd like you to
meet uh and yet you know oftentimes the
problem with basic research that you and
i traffic in is that it does produce
technology uh and and then people expect
the you know the jackpot to keep paying
out not just with nobel prizes but with
technology and um i want to take a
statement that i really love this this
book harry it's such a great book i
found out you know i i loved your
interview you did with lex friedman our
mutual friend and and he called you one
of the greatest scientific communicators
and i didn't realize how great a writer
you are but it was really uh such a
delight to go through this book because
it's actually a stealth
kind of chemistry book as i say in the
tradition of gen 11 but also in the
tradition of isaac asimov
who was a great writer
but both of of science fiction but of
science fact and he was a chemist and
and uh his book through the history of
chemistry really hooked me on science
and i and i uh back as a 12 year old and
i hope that this will do the same for
other young people as was your intent so
you're to be commended on that one of
the things the themes that comes up is
the concept of a historic experiment and
you mentioned just recently rutherford
and you called him his experiment you
know one of the first historic
experiments talk about what what that
means what is a historic experiment are
there still historic experiments what is
that nature why are they so crucial in
your opinion
yeah i guess by historic experiments i
suppose that we're referring to
these moments where you know someone
gets hands-on with nature and discovers
something really profound and there are
a number i go through quite a few of
these in the book um
you know actually one of the earliest
ones i think i mentioned is quite a sort
of fun one which is um anton antoine
lavoisier who is uh what was seen as one
of the fathers of modern chemistry or
the father of modern chemistry and he
did this experiment where he had this he
sort of done a lot of work on combustion
and chemical reactions and and also the
sort of early version of the periodic
table or at least at least the first
list of chemical elements um
and he was sort of became interested in
do animals combust their food in other
words is there a form of combustion
taking place inside animals and he did
this experiment famously where he put a
guinea pig in this bucket of ice
effectively and is that essentially
built a calorimeter energy measuring
device and he measured how much um
ice the guinea pig's heat melted and
used this to work out that it sort of
energy release was roughly you know
concordant with what you'd expect from
combustion and sort of concluded that
this is sort of what's going on in
respiration it's also interesting the
origin of the term to be a scientific
guinea pig this was the original guinea
pig
but you know so there's ones like that
in terms of the sort of physics there's
you know there are several of these um
throughout the book i mean
probably the experiment that begins what
we would regard as modern particle
physics is
jj thompson's discovery of the electron
so this is the first fundamental
particle that was ever discovered it was
discovered in 1897 and it's amazing
really when you consider that thompson
did this experiment was really pretty i
mean okay
not basic equipment because actually for
its time there's a lot of craft involved
in making the equipment that he used so
he had this this was he used his glass
tube a cathode ray tube which was hand
blown by this very skilled uh technician
called ebenezer everett who he worked
with but it was essentially an
experiment done by two people in a
university laboratory with very little
resources or money apart from their own
skills as experimenters and craftspeople
and they discovered you know the first
real proof that there is something
smaller than the atom and this is the
beginning of our proper understanding of
you know why chemistry is the way it is
but also the structure of matter that
goes on and you think about you know the
last particle to be discovered so you
know to date is the higgs and that took
a machine that's 27 kilometers long cost
12 billion euros to build there's
thousands of people working on it so
this incredible change in scale but so i
suppose you have you know you have that
at the one end of this you know very
modest historic experiment that really
changes our understanding of the nature
and today the lhc i think the discovery
of the higgs will in a century's time
when we look back be regarded as another
one of these historic experiments but
the scale is now
unimaginable to what thompson could have
thought of you know in the 1890s for
sure
absolutely and um i look at as an
experimentalist i try to see you know by
what
physical evidence can we do what david
hilbert said uh in this notion of
compression in other words how many
um previous theories or conjectures can
be eliminated um by a new theory and i
think in the case of you know like
priestly and and lawsuit et cetera
getting rid of things like flogist in uh
what you talk about obviously you need
to talk about you know cooking and
combustion if you're talking about your
cooking recipes and and you know how
they eliminated these types of things
and there are many such such examples
throughout the book one of which you
know kind of dovetails i interview as i
say you know some of my best friends are
theorists
and and i interviewed them on regular
occasion and you know one of the things
i always wonder about is when do you
know if you can trust a theorist i don't
mean like you know are they gonna swipe
your car or something like that but but
how can you trust you know what they're
saying when half the time they get their
own predictions wrong or
are maybe undercut what they're capable
of revealing in this compression
algorithm that hilbert speaks about for
example you talk about kinetic theory
and brownian motion
in the book and of course einstein's
contributions to that were crucial and
decisive
uh and yet uh he really in that paper
calls upon uh uh you know calls upon
experimentalists to test out and i think
you mentioned this french physicist
peran
and then that was later you know
verified and that you know eventually
many decades later leads to you know
success nobel prize et cetera
but um
but then of course he also used the
equations of gr to retrodict or to
explain the anomalous procession of the
perihelion of mercury
and
and on the other hand he was very much
in error about the implications of gr
when it came to gravitational lensing
when it came to strong gravitational
lensing when it came to gravitational
waves when it came to the expansion of
the universe
so how do we know when to trust this guy
i mean i i have a conjecture i want to
get your reaction to it i want you to
grade me
i believe you should trust a theorist
almost all the time if they make a
prediction a retrodiction in other words
they explain existing phenomena and it
makes sense on the other hand if they
make if they say that something that
can't be done as as uh namesake of this
center that i caught a record arthur c
clarke said when an elder but
distinguished scientist says something
is impossible he's almost always wrong
so how do you know when to trust your
theorist colleagues
you know et cetera how do you know that
they're
appropriately taking into account the
existing data and evidence that we have
but also you know standing on firm
ground and then maybe uh extrapolating
when they're too when they're too timid
and they don't realize what the
implications are how do you know when to
trust a theorist like if you were alive
back in 1905
would you have trusted
i think it's it's a really interesting
question i mean
i think one of the things in modern
science that has happened is because
science is so much bigger and it's so
much more developed than it was a
hundred years ago there's a much higher
degree of sub-specialism than there was
so you know a hundred years ago so
thompson who discovered the scare of the
electron he was actually a mathematical
physicist by training he was a theorist
really um but he he kind of you know
became he was rather strangely appointed
the head of the candidates laboratories
experimental laboratory which everyone
was very surprised about because he was
actually famously clumsy often would
break his own experiments and you know
but nonetheless you had someone there
working both as an experimenter and as a
theory so he was coming up with ideas
and then
himself testing them which is very rare
these days i mean
at the lhc in high energy physics
there's a kind of hierarchy or
or a
you know a kind of taxonomy of different
sorts of people you have even within
experimental physics there's the people
who are the sort of hardware experts
people like me who do data analysis then
you've got the theory side you have the
phenomenologists who are sort of using
the fundamental theories to try to
connect to experiment directly but then
you've got people doing the really sort
of fundamental big picture stuff and
it's not that these people can't always
talk to each other you know very very
easily because they don't speak the same
language so you know people that i work
most closely with are phenomenologists
who are sort of the close closest
theorists to experimentalists that there
are but you know if i was going to go
and talk to a string theorist i would
have no idea what they were saying so
a lot of this has to be in a sense it
sort of does have to be taken on trust
because you if you're an experimenter
there's no real way you can actually
assess you know someone's theoretical
ideas it has to be based on you know do
i trust this person do i know their
reputation what do other people say
about their work do they seem like
they're kind of methodical what's their
track record so it's it's a kind of
complicated thing actually um and it and
it's a crucial thing at the moment i
mean maybe we'll get onto this but
what's happening in
lhcb at the moment the experiment i work
on is we're seeing these anomalies uh
which seem to disagree with the standard
model our current best theory of
particle physics and
one of the big questions is
is it that you know there's several
possibilities when we're seeing these
things is that one it's genuinely like
new physics and it's a big breakthrough
but there's a lot of much more mundane
ones and it could be an experimental
error that we've made on our side but it
could also be a theoretical effect
that's been missed because the
calculations that from the theory side
that are being made are very complicated
and you have to take into all kinds of
difficult calculations in order to do
them and
you know that there's a lot of doubt
about you know a famous one that came
out this year for example was this muon
measurement from the mu1 g minus two
experiment in fermilab and the big
debate there is again they see this
discrepancy between the magnetism of the
muon in their experiment and what theory
says it ought to be but then there's
another theory prediction that's much
closer to the experiment and they dis
they have different techniques for
calculating various effects and you know
it looks like the question there is
really which theory do you trust the
experiment seems pretty solid um so it's
a hard it's a hard question i guess
ultimately the answer is nature will
find you out in the end because you know
even if you're i think it's fineman's
very famous quote about you know doesn't
matter if you're a theory it doesn't
matter how smart you are doesn't matter
you know who made the prediction what
their what their name is what their
reputation if it disagrees with
experiment it's wrong and eventually
experiment we'll find find out who will
settle you know the argument i suppose
but it's it's not there's not an easy
answer i don't think actually
well you go through in a very tender
detail you know as i said the the
history of chemistry and leading up to
um the final reductionist um
you know clarion calls of the 1900s and
obviously concluding with the the role
that the lhc has played and even
speculating where we can go
uh farther and you know as i'm reading
it again i'm feeling inspired and
depressed uh because inspired because of
how much we know and how much we know
that we don't know
but also the the notion that uh the next
you know uh the next apples on the tree
are very high up uh in in that uh it's
going to be very difficult to make
progress experimentally and if that's
the rubric you know as feynman says and
i agree with feynman obviously even
though he was a theorist
i i agree with that deep connection uh
and yet it it's depressing because in a
sense i do feel there is a lot of hype
and especially in both of our fields in
experimental cosmology where we now kind
of gearing up to build uh to build a
next generation so-called stage four cmb
experiment to measure the polarization
the b mode polarization of the cmb
looking for a single number effectively
which is the amount of gravitational
wave energy primordially uh in the early
universe attributable to inflation uh
what worries me is that inflation might
not have happened or it might have
happened at a very low energy scale that
we can never detect won't produce and
i'm not saying we won't get ancillary
benefits obviously the simon's
observatory in simon's array that i
co-lead these are projects that are also
in some sense you know searching for
that as the primary target and we could
do a lot of other physics as well but
that's the other physics is not why we
would build it just like i don't believe
that you know building you know the lhc
uh was was built you know primarily to
discover the higgs and now that i've
discovered that um there's other
justifications but the justification
that bigger is better uh it seems to
ring a little bit more hollow uh in in
this
era of constrained but now budgets are
always constrained and you go through
the calculations
um of how much it would really cost and
how little that is on the ground scale
and then a delightful science fiction
you know vignette at the very end which
i won't spoil because i just loved i
loved listening to the audiobook i
thought that was delightful to hear your
voice um but when you you know have to
sell it um i as feynman also said i hope
you never in his famous you know uh the
first principle is not to fool yourself
he also says at the end i hope you'll
never compromise your principles to get
money
meaning that you know to get the
experiment that he claims necessary to
validate a theory that you won't like
oversell it uh because as he said one of
his depressing moments was when the
scientist said well if we told them you
know the reality they'd never fund us um
so when the when the when the apples are
so much higher up the the next level
beyond the higgs is so far away how can
we justify it and is that not depressing
to you
yeah i mean well
i
it's definitely a challenge just to to
make the case for these projects for
sure i would say that it's
i mean i make this point in the book
that the next machine
if there is an x machine the big
question we're trying to answer now is
what is the higgs boson in essence so we
with the hex has been discovered it
seems to be the one that's predicted but
you know there are reasons for you know
there are strong theoretical reasons for
believing that an object like the higgs
should not exist it should not be
possible and
the the main goal of the next machine
will basically be to study the higgs at
the highest details possible and this is
this question is actually you know it's
sort of
the question that this next machine will
have to be trying to answer is sort of
the fundamental shift i think that's
been happening in the last 10 years it's
associated with that and i don't know
how technical we want to get but
basically there's this problem known as
the fine-tuning problem or the hierarchy
problem to do with the higgs which is
that the more more technical the better
actually telecoil better yeah so okay so
the higgs boson is a vibration in this
thing called the higgs field and the
higgs field is unique amongst the
quantum fields that we know about that
make up the world around us in that it
has a uniform non-zero value everywhere
in space it's like the whole of space
has this kind of
amount of higgsiness that fills it and
that that sort of amount of energy in
the higgs field is responsible for the
masses of elementary particles it's also
and the structure of the fundamental
forces that we observe in the universe
around us but there's this weird thing
that
this value that the higgs field has
seems to be incredibly unlikely and if
you do a sort of naive calculation using
quantum field theory with some
assumptions about you know how far up in
energy you can go to the planck scale
you find that there should really only
be two natural answers to how strong
should the higgs field be and it's
either that it's off it goes to gets
pushed to zero or it gets whacked way up
to the plank energy this enormous energy
scale and in either of those two
scenarios we wouldn't be here because in
the in this case where the higgs field
is off
electrons for one have no mass in fact
all the fundamental particles would be
rearranged and the whole universe looked
totally different but you would there
would certainly not be structures that
we would recognize so we could not exist
in such a universe and
the other option is where it's at the
planck scale then everything gets so
heavy it collapses into a black hole and
again you have no structure and we have
this to achieve this weird value which
is in in particle physics units the
value of the higgs field we think is
about 256 giga electron volts more or
less i think that's right
and there was the the planck scale is
something like 10 billion billion giga
electron volts and zero is zero so it's
sort of why is it this very small value
which isn't this enormous scale and it's
also not zero and the only way to do
this is to
finely tune the
the fundamental constants of nature to a
ridiculously unbelievable extent so this
this big question the
one of the main reasons for believing
that there would be new particles at the
lhc beyond the higgs is that there's an
expectation there needs to be some new
physics associated with the higgs boson
that stabilizes the higgs field and
allows the universe as we know it to
exist and
so far at least all the searches that
have been made at the lhc have not yet
turned up the signs of the predicted new
physics so there's this question you
know
is the universe and this is at least a
bifurcation in how we think about
fundamental physics you know we have
this weird feature of the world
can we explain it in terms of new
phenomena when we zoom in zoom in we'll
discover there are new particles new
dynamics that will explain this fact or
do we have to somehow we start relying
on anthropic arguments you know in terms
of multiverses where the higgsville
higgs field has different values in
different parts of the multiverse and we
live in the bit we do because it's the
only one we can live in and so on and
and that sort of goes to the really deep
into the heart of what we mean by you
know the kind of questions we can ask in
science because
i think i think a lot of i don't know i
think a lot of people start off at least
with a distaste for the multiverse
because it sort of says well you can't
answer this question because
it's probably set by multi some
multiverse argument which we can't test
and can't you know do any
experimentation to see if it's right but
we'll just have to sort of take it as
assumed
so
what this next machine will do is settle
that argument one way or another because
actually the lhc is this point was made
to me uh by nima alkani hamad when i
interviewed him for the book that the
machine that everyone really wanted was
the super conducting super collider
which was this american
uh project that was being built actually
in the early 90s and late 80s in texas
and it was going to be 80 kilometers
long it was going to go up to an energy
about three times higher than the lhc
and it got cancelled because of budget
problems and political problems and
that the lhc is sort of almost like a
sort of smaller compromise a sort of
consolation prize in a way and actually
it doesn't really go up to the energies
you need to really test this problem so
basically you know if you want to sort
of the higgs b basically the higgs we've
seen this thing but we can't we haven't
got the resolution to zoom in on it and
really study it in detail and understand
you know
is it is it actually made of smaller
things is the higgs a composite particle
for example which would explain this
problem potentially and we can't we can
do that a bit of the lhc but we can't
settle it and the next machine's job is
really to settle this question that's
the big that's the big selling point and
there are a bunch of other there are
lots of other things that can do dark
matter matter antimatter asymmetry you
name it you know the thing about
colliders is they're very very rich
places to do science because you can ask
a huge number of different questions
with a collider um and but you know if
you think this question with the higgs
is an is a is an important question to
answer i think a lot of people would say
on its own that's the reason
for doing it and the other stuff is more
you know that's when we know we'll get
an answer to one way or another and we
may not like the answer we get but but
it will at least settle the debate and
we may also get
answers about dark matter about loads of
other things potentially but there's no
guarantee of that so yeah that's that's
the scientific argument for doing it and
it really comes down to i think do you
think this question is important enough
to justify these experiments but
i think if you say that it's not then
you're sort of saying well okay we're
going to give up on this type of
fundamental physics to an extent i mean
there are things you can do at low
energy experiments that can give you
sensitivity to what's going on at higher
energy scales but you know only in a
sort of usually quite restricted sort of
scenarios so if you say we're going to
stop at this point well you know we're
kind of having to sort of in a sense say
well that's the end of this this kind of
exploratory science at least for the
time being um yeah so i think that's why
we we still have to push and make the
case for this um
and maybe we'll get on to this but i
mean the other big argument that may be
there and it still depends what happens
at the lhc is these anomalies again and
if these anomalies
turn out to be confirmed they are
indicating
uh the existence of particles that
could be with that well
almost certainly would be within the
energy range of the next generation
collider so that would be a kind of
guaranteed win if these anomalies turn
out but maybe we'll talk about that in a
bit
yeah yeah actually let's go there so
today um the cern courier published a
nice interview with edward witten um
you know at no point will be a guest on
this podcast i've already asked and been
rejected uh ema has has promised me he's
going to come on but uh it's proving
harder and harder as time goes on uh but
uh in this interview with the cern
courier uh which i'll have a link to in
the show notes uh he says you know it's
uh for you know people love to say if
such and such will happen at an energy
scale not too much above the lhc
energies
and you go through in the book you know
how hard it is to to go up by you know
ten percent let alone you know three
times six times 25 times uh so the the
you know he claims the dream would be to
get a concrete clue from the current
experiments about what is the energy
scale for new physics beyond the higgs
particle and the interviewer asked the
follow-up question could the flavor
anomalies be one such clue and he says
there's multiple places the possible
anomalies in b physics observed at cern
are extremely significant
if they hold up
so i want to talk about that and your
recent results from october
in which you reported a number uh
very uh you know i was going to get a
tattoo of this
rsa
superscript 0 sub s and r sub k
superscript asterisk plus uh which were
detected at uh at several sigma um what
the heck is this what are these numbers
what do they mean uh in in simple terms
so we can get a detailed in just a bit
but what is the basis of this what first
of all what's a b
um
and
what is b physics going to tell us and
how could it imply perhaps a clue
to the existence of new physics that's
testable with the current technology
that we have not some future collider
what what is b physics and what are
these strange symbols
so well b stands for beauty which is the
name which is usually applied to one of
the six quarks by b physicist so we tend
to call the what's usually called the
bottom quark we call the beauty quark
for strange historical reasons i guess
because we'd rather be beauty physicists
than bottom physicists and um
these are this is the fifth heaviest of
the quark it's the so there are six
quarks in three generations two in each
generation it's the heaviest down type
quark so this is the the very heavy
version of the down quark that's inside
protons and neutrons and these things
are really interesting because they are
relatively long-lived so they because of
the way they interact through the weak
interaction they live for in particle
physics terms a long time about one and
a half trillionths of a second on
average before they decay and they can
decay into most of the particles in the
standard model because of their mass um
and that gives it that makes them a
really rich
sort of area to do physics and they're
made in huge numbers in the lhc
collisions so when you bang protons
together because protons are made of
quarks and gluons you tend to make lots
of quarks and gluons including billions
and billions of these beauty quarks
every year
and the particular area i work in is in
very rare decays of these beauty quarks
so you see create one of these things it
lives a little bit of time trillionth of
a second or so and then it decays and
there are particular decays that are
extremely rare by which we mean that you
know if you have a million beauty quarks
one of them might decay like this and
there's a particular set of processes
where basically a beauty quark
transforms into a strange quark which is
the the sort of next lightest version of
the down quark so it's the next one
along in the generations and emits
either
a muon and an anti-muon
and a muon is a heavy version of the
electron basically or an electron and an
anti-electron and what we've seen lhcb
over the last were sort of getting on
for seven years now is that
if you take a a ratio of how often a
beauty quark divide goes into a strange
quark and two muons and divide that by
how often it goes into a strange quark
and two electrons
this rate
this ratio you can predict very
precisely in the standard model and it
should be one and the reason basically
is that electrons and muons are kind of
like copies of each other they're
identical in every way they interact
with the forces with the same strength
they have all the same properties the
only way they're different is their mass
and the muon is about 200 times heavier
than the electron but other than that
they're identical so all because all the
forces interact with these particles at
the same rate you also expect or the
same strength you also expect beauty
quarks to decay into muons and electrons
equally so they should you should get
the same numbers of these different
decays and what we've seen consistently
in a number of different data sets and
with different you know teams of people
measuring them in different decay
processes we're seeing that the muon
decay seems to be happening less often
than the electron decay
and the reason this is a really powerful
measurement is because i sort of talked
about theoretical uncertainties and one
of the problems with these decays
is not just a measurement but also
predicting theoretically
say how often should such a process
happen
but because you take a ratio between
these almost identical processes all the
theory uncertainties cancel so you get a
quantity that is this really pristine
very precisely predicted number with a
very small uncertainty and everyone
agrees that this number should be one to
several decimal places and if it isn't
one the only way you can explain this is
if there's new physics um and what we've
seen
consistently over time is that this
number is below one it turns it comes in
at around on average 0.8.85 something
like that
and what we've done over years is we've
measured different types of these decays
basically the difference between them is
that the beauty quark you don't see the
beauty quark on its own it's always
coupled up with other particles usually
an antiquark so it can be you can have a
beauty quark uh with an up quark for
example or an anti-up quark technically
or you can have a beauty quark and an
anti-down quark or a beauty quark and an
anti-strange quark and there's this
spectator quark which doesn't actually
do anything it just kind of sits there
and while the beauty quark does its
thing that means you observe different
particles in your detector because what
you see is the composite state not the
the fundamental particle so what what i
measured with a student of mine john
smeaton over the last few years has been
two of these decays basically one of
which is a beauty quark with an up quark
and the other one which is a beauty
quark with a down quark and what we
found using all the data that's
available from lhcb so far is that again
this number comes out below one it you
know agrees really well with the other
anomalies that have been seen
and this is sort of you know gradually
strengthening picture
with anomalies what usually happens is
if if they are a
there's this question in
particle physics is you know you might
see an effect that's two sigma away from
your standard model prediction say well
two sigma effects come and go all the
time you do loads of measurements some
of them will wander away from your
theoretical prediction and
when you get an anomaly like that what
happens is you add data usually as it
disappears it goes back into
back to the standard model and we've
seen this historically in 2015 there was
this big excitement over this thing
called the die photon bump which was uh
a wiggle in a graph that turned up in
atlas and cms is um data right
in 750 publications yeah it yeah it was
how many were actually published but
it was it was amazing yeah i mean the
this little bump in a graph here
theorists went absolutely nuts and the
archive was flooded with explanations to
what this thing was and and when they
added more data a few months later in
2016 this bump disappeared and it turned
out to be a statistical fluke
and that hasn't happened when we've
added data almost always what's happened
is the effect is strengthened and
this isn't just in these ratios there
are other things you can do you can look
at the angles the particles come out at
you can look at the absolute rates how
often do these things happen all of
these things disagree with the standard
model and the other those other
measurements have theory uncertainties
associated with them so it's not quite
so clear but what i think is
getting a lot of theorists excited is
that all these anomalies appear to be
coherent in the sense that you can
explain them all simultaneously with a
relatively simple
new addition to the the standard model
adding a new particle of some new force
particle usually of some type and i
think it's that's why people in b
physics people who know about b physics
are getting more and more excited and
you know the latest result that we
produced is just another bit of evidence
that strengthens this case and
the the kind of the the real question
now is
are these anomalies
genuine new physics
or is there some conspiracy of
systematic effects
theoretical errors that are somehow
fooling us into thinking we're seeing
something and that is the big question
now because you know if if this if these
anomalies are real it's like it's a
super big deal this is this is the this
will be the first time
that we have seen and i've been a bit
careful but i think it's not totally
unjustified to say the first time we've
seen something new in fundamental
physics and in particle physics that
wasn't predicted in advance
you know by the standard model since the
1970s right because
pretty much all the discoveries that
have been the major ones the w the z
bosons the higgs boson the top quark you
know all these things
were anticipated before they were found
they're part of a coherent picture
whereas this is something absolutely new
that isn't part of the standard model
and if it's real it's going to tell us
something very profound about the
structure of the standard model itself
why the particles that we see in nature
exist and possibly it could also be
connected to dark matter this problem
with the higgs who knows but it's going
to open up a new window so it's it's a
kind of really exciting moment and a
very high stakes moment because we still
don't know yet
is this real
is it some
conspiracy of mistakes and we don't
think it's a mistake these measurements
are you know they've huge care is taken
they've been they've been cross-checked
by different teams within the experiment
but what we really need now is
new measurements that can kind of
confirm the picture one way or another
and a new theory as well to help us
check whether there are theoretical
errors there
one question i have is you know to what
extent are these really like fifth
forces and new forces versus
modifications of you know the existing
you know symmetries that we do believe
exist um they they're anomalies in that
sense so their anomalies and something
that's pre-existing
uh you know in what sense is it like
saying well
einstein's gr is a new force i mean it
seems like no there is one underlying
force we just didn't understand it
there's some anomalies mercury and other
things um so to what extent is it really
uh accurate uh when we when we talk
about these things to say
you know
effectively that they are producing some
uh some new fifth floor so i guess the
concrete question is yeah are these
really
forces new forces are they modifications
anomalies corrected anomalies and
existing forces and in other words is
the fifth force talk all kind of a
little bit of hype
no it's not hype um
for the very simple reason that all of
the forces we know about
interact and they must interact because
of the symmetries that generate them in
the standard model with the
the leptons the electron mu and the tau
with equal strength and the you know you
can't modify the weak force and explain
these anomalies that way so the the weak
force has also been tested very
thoroughly we know the form of the weak
force the strong force the
electromagnetic force so it's no it's
not a modification of the new forces
it's got to be something it's got to be
a new technically a new gauge boson of
some type
and there are a couple of a couple of
leading candidates there's something
called a z prime which is effectively a
bit like the z boson of the standard
model but with a heavier with different
sorts of interactions coming from a
different sort of symmetry or it could
be probably the more exciting option is
something called electro quark which is
again a a boson of some type it could
either be a vector or a scalar so either
it can be spin one like a force particle
or it could be like the higgs
potentially which is a spinless particle
so okay in terms of new force it depends
a little bit what you mean by force but
colloquially you know if it's if it's a
boson it's a force i think so it's not
it's not illegitimate to say it's a new
force but i mean the thing that's i mean
the new force is cool and that's
exciting and that's great and everything
else but and it's a kind of it's a it's
a short hat it's a short way of
explaining what we're seeing
but if
the thing that's really exciting about
this is not so much that there's a new
force i mean the reason we've never seen
this before is if it is there this force
is very weak and only becomes manifest
at very short distance scales you know
which we're probing at the lhc which is
why we're only seeing it now potentially
but the thing that's exciting about this
is if it's really there it's probably
telling us something pretty fundamental
about one of the big mysteries of the
standard model which has kind of been
ignored for quite a long time which is
this fact that the mata particles come
in three generations so we see in nature
that the universe around us is what we
can observe at least is made of the
first generation of matter for the most
part so it's made of up and down quarks
that make up protons and neutrons that
make up atomic nuclei and electrons and
they're in the first generation and then
there's the second generation with the
charm and the strange quark and the the
muon and the neutrino that goes with
that and and then in the fourth
generation the top and bottom quark and
the tau and we don't know why there are
three generations and there are attempts
to explain this in the 70s and 80s with
grand unified theories these are
theories that unified the strong
interaction with the electroweak
interaction and quite often also
included the mata particles in that is
sort of some bigger symmetry group and
this those sort of theories went a bit
by the wayside because they predicted
that protons should decay and
experiments that were done in the 80s
and 90s showed that protons do not decay
at the rate at least that these theories
predicted and the energy scales of
ground unified theories is enormous way
beyond the scale we can probe at
colliders but
because these forces if they're there
treat
the different generations differently
they clearly interact with the you know
the second generation in a different way
to the first generation we can say that
if it's a real thing it's telling us
something about why there are three and
the sort of the exciting ideas there
with these lecture quarks is that there
actually is a new symmetry
that kind of explains basically what
actually these models effectively say is
that
the reason we have
uh leptons and quarks is actually the
the electron say is actually a fourth
type of quark which is part of a sort of
bigger symmetry group along with the
others and so this is getting i'm
getting i'm not explaining myself very
well but in in the strong interactions
fundamental physics you have the charge
of the strong interaction is called
color and there are three colors red
green and blue
and the quarks carry color the electron
and the muon the tau don't and they
that's why they don't interact with a
strong interaction well these new
theories that include these leptoquarks
treat the electrons as having a fourth
color which and this this whole bigger
symmetry breaks down at low energy into
the strong interaction that we're
familiar with and a leftover bit which
is actually ends up being part of the
electromagnetic force but i mean there's
a long story short basically is it kind
of will be part of a bigger more
symmetrical unified theory that explains
probably something well certainly
something about the structure of the
mata particles but quite likely as well
about the unification of forces in some
in some sense as well so it's it's a big
step forward if indeed it it's confirmed
but that's the big if but it's so i mean
that was a long answer your question but
it's not hyped to say this is a new
force but it's actually more exciting
than that i would argue
the next question i've had on my mind
for a long time
is that we know of one elementary boson
that has spin zero only one in the
universe we think maybe the inflaton
also is spin zero and with the existence
of the higgs i think that led some
credulity or hope at least that we could
um have more credulity in the higgs
existence we have spin one half fermions
and then we have spin one and hopefully
maybe even spin two uh bosons uh
respectively the photons and and
gravitons uh but there are no spin three
halves fermions um or what would you
even call them are there theories and
are there ways to test why why is this
missing you know gap you talk in the
book about the
formation of light elements you go back
to gamma and the burbidges who are my
late great colleagues here at uc san
diego talk about that and hoyle
and fowler
and this missing gap is there a missing
gap analog that precludes the existence
of a spin three halves uh elementary
particle
well so this is now not really my area
but i do know a little bit about it in
the sensor so i think the spin three
half particle if it's there is it's
predicted by
supersymmetry for example so it's the
super version of the graviton so in
supersymmetry you have the symmetry
between bosons and fermions and the
fermions in the standard model or get
bosonic versions so fermions have spin
half and they get spin zero partners and
this and the boson so it's just been one
gets been half partners and the graviton
the super graviton or gravitino i think
it's usually referred to as gets a spin
three halves particle because the
graviton has spin too but i mean
as you know uh the last 10 years super
symmetry was was the kind of the hot
topic when the lhc switched on and a lot
of my colleagues were very excited that
we were going to see super particles
being produced at the lhc in such huge
numbers that our data our data flow
wouldn't be able to cope with it and and
actually none of these things showed up
so i mean
that that does that isn't to say that
supersymmetry is wrong because you know
supersymmetry can exist at any energy
scale that the reason for thinking that
it was accessible at the lhc was to do
with this argument about the higgs boson
and fine tuning and naturalness and so
on and that was why you expect it to
turn up at the lhc's energies if you
don't buy that argument though
supersymmetry can be any scale including
all the way up to the the planck scale
so these spin three halves things could
be out there
so far we have no evidence of them but
you know we will have to wait and see uh
but uh yeah no no info so far at least
i'm afraid but they're certainly
possible
oh very good uh and then next i want to
pivot to the extremely
early universe in which many things
occur
including uh something that at least in
the context of stellar nucleosynthesis
you talk about is almost miraculous uh
and indeed hoyle himself called the
formation
of of carbon within uh the cores of of
of hot young stars as a type of miracle
this uh famous beryllium resonance that
you described um are you troubled at all
by some of the you know these
fine-tuning issues i mean very famous
ones involve things that you talk about
um
in the book from you know the formation
of the lightness elements and the
various time scales and the uh and the
necessity for the sakurao condition that
requires um conversion of uh of
antiquarks into quarks it is
you know by these stalerons which you do
an extremely good job of describing
um how many mystery how many
miracles can can one science tolerate
uh you know
when we you know
i've had on you know intelligent design
advocates i've had on you know avowed
atheists and uh this is either an
embarrassment or you know and and even
in this article by whitten that i'll
link in the show notes you know he talks
about well now he's he used to be really
against the anthropic arguments but now
he's coming to see you know especially
if the landscape is true uh and uh
how many
miracles and landscapes and and
multiverses can one field tolerate
yeah it's a it's a good question i mean
i
i suppose you know the ideal situation
would be that so take the beryllium
resonance that is responsible for the
production of carbon in in red giants
like you know this is pretty finely
tuned and if you move the resonance
energy one way or another then it all
goes wrong and there's a similar
resonance in oxygen that if you had a
resonance at a certain energy all the
carbon in the universe would turn into
oxygen straight away there'd be no
carbon which would be a problem for us
um
so like hoyle famously had this this
kind of moment after the discovery of
these of the brilliant resonance when he
was at caltech uh with uh with fowler
um you know so this sort of amazement at
the state of affairs that allowed
the elements that we know and love and
are made from to exist
i suppose the ideal would be that you
know from the fundamental theory of
quarks and gluons you'd be able to
calculate why this
resonance is inevitable you know in some
sense but we're not as far as i
understand it our nuclear theory isn't
at the the stage where we can we can
really we do that and address that
question i mean
i think that there's uh
in terms of the multiverse and
landscapes and fine-tuning is turf is
perfectly philosophically coherent to
say
that there may well be features of the
universe that you know
happened just because of random chance
because we can only exist in the
universe we do because of the laws of
nature being conducive to us existing
that's perfectly fine and i don't think
there's anything wrong with making those
sorts of arguments i suppose the problem
from my point of view is that i don't
think they lead you anywhere
you kind of if you accept that view it
it's not clear to me
where you go after that apart from just
saying oh okay it's the maybe it's the
multiverse but you know
i made this point in the book which is
that yeah the multiverse is a perfectly
rational idea in the sense that every
time we discover something new about the
universe you go back to
copernicus say where you know the
argument is is the earth the central
universe is it special at the center of
everything or is it orbiting the sun and
then you know we we kind of realize
that's the case and then we zoom out we
realize the sun is one of the number of
stars and the sun isn't particularly
special it's also not the central
universe and then we realized that the
milky way which was which in the 19
early you know early 20th century was
thought to be the entire universe you
realize it's not the entire universe
there are other island universes other
galaxies out there so a whole of the
history of science has been this gradual
realization that where we live is not
unique or special so why should our
universe be unique or special but
there's a big problem there which is the
universe by definition is the only is
the thing we live in and it's the only
thing we can observe so
we can't tell if the multiverse is there
maybe we can make clever theoretical
arguments based on string theory and
inflation and what have you and that's
fine but you know in the absence of
evidence for those things it's
experimentally again you're in a bit of
a bind so
i think it's fine to make those sorts of
arguments but personally i think we
should only really go to that place
where we've exhausted every other
possible explanation so
that's in a sense why this question by
the higgs is important you know we could
some people might be happy already to
say oh the higgs is value it's fine
tuned it's just because of the
multiverse and okay fine then you stop
answering asking a question but then
that may not be right right then there
may be new physics and dynamics out
there that we haven't discovered that
explains this fact and if we accept the
multiverse argument then we stop looking
for those answers and the subject dies
so
i think we we have to acknowledge these
things are possible and they could well
be right but
i don't think we should be too ready to
accept them before we've really
exhausted every part of our imagination
and ingenuity and trying to find
alternatives and they should really be a
last resort i want to pivot now towards
you know what i love the most about um
how to make an apple pie from scratch is
kind of the gulliver's travels
aspect where you're kind of uh going
around the world and meeting all these
people from astrophysicists to
gravitational wave physicists to
experimental fellow particle physicists
making anti-hydrogen to make anti-apple
pies uh and uh and i just love that
about it i wanna ask you what what
attracts you and what intoxicates you
what what do you love the most about
what you do and and to get there first
um tell me how what is it that you do
i'm not i'm not reviewing you you know
you haven't applied to ucsd for a
position as far as i know although our
your colleagues here are uh you know
would probably love that um what do you
do
so i was i work on the lhcp experiment
which is one of four big experiments on
the lhc ring so i'm a member of a team
of about 1400 people mixture of
physicists computer scientists engineers
and you know what the experiment itself
does is it studies these beauty quarks
or not just beauty quarks it does a load
of stuff mostly beauty cards but also
other things as well
my day job is really data analysis so
i'm some i'm my main activity is looking
at the data that comes out of lhcb and
trying to glean things about the
behavior of beauty quarks in particular
these rare decays so if you if you watch
me doing my day-to-day it will be mostly
sitting in front of you know a terminal
window with some code open and you know
so there's a kind of various aspects of
the job i mean one of the things i've
been doing just this week is
we're preparing for run three of the
large hadron colliders the lhc has been
in a shutdown for the last two years and
during that period of shutdown lhcb has
been more or less completely replaced
with new detector components but in
order to allow the experiment to read
out data at a much faster rate so the
lhc collides protons 40 million times
every second previously we were only
capable of reading out one million times
a second so we yeah basically you know
most of the data we were immediately
throwing away before we did any kind of
analysis of it and the new experiment is
going to be able to read out the full
lhc collision rate and to do that
one of the things that we now have to do
is in real time for every collision you
have to have an algorithm that analyzes
collision by collision and looks for the
thing that you're interested in so you
know is there a beauty quark decaying
into one of these rare decays for
example and this is what we call a
trigger in particle physics so i spent a
lot of the last week writing a trigger
or various triggers actually for a load
of these different rare decays so when
we start taking data hopefully in the
spring uh we'll start to get you know
more data added to the pile so we can
check out these anomalies so
that that this kind of that stuff is
actually um what i've been doing there
is relatively simple it's basically
coming up with some requirements so you
say the particle's got to have a
momentum bigger than this and its energy
is going to be bigger than this and it
has to be pointing in this direction and
use various of these sort of kinematic
properties to decide whether you're
seeing something interesting um the
other i mean
down the line what we'll do is use
machine learning so we already do a lot
of this on the offline side when we're
analyzing data where you train
uh decision trees booster decision trees
neural networks to you basically
classify your collisions and sort of say
does this thing the main one of the big
problems is you have a huge volume of
data and the things you're looking for
is are very rare so you've got to sift
these little specks of gold dust from
this huge pile of dirt
in essence and the way we do that is
using pattern recognition machine
learning to sift this stuff out that's
another big part of the job and then
there's also the that's probably the
easier bit of the job the harder bit is
when you're trying to make a measurement
and you know the measurement i've just
been working on to give you a sense that
this ratio of electrons and muons
it took about four years to make this
measurement and the reason it takes such
a long time is because
to measure this number precisely and be
confident that you've not you know
missed some systematic bias you have to
take into account all kinds of different
possible effects these these experiments
are huge and they're incredibly
complicated and there's all kinds of
things you have to account for and
correct for in order to actually make
the measurement you want to make and
that's where most of the work really is
actually ultimately so it's chasing down
hidden biases problems with your
simulated data you know effects you
might have missed and that's that's the
day job i mean in terms of what it looks
like a lot of it is writing computer
code although that usually actually only
happens once you've thought the problem
through and think you might have a
solution or an answer and then other
than that it's discussing with your
colleagues and trying to figure out you
know we're seeing this weird effect how
what is it what's causing it what do we
need to do to address it
yeah so all right it's uh frequently
said as isaac asimov once uh mentioned
that the most
uh traditional or typical scientific
reaction to new surprising information
is not eureka
i have found it but that's freaking
weird
i think i think what i actually said
because
my next book is actually on about this
exact topic which is it's going to be
about anomalies and you know the role
that they play because you know there's
anomalies in particle physics at the
moment there's also anomalies in
cosmology as you know well you know the
hubble tension these other things that
are going on and it's we've been this
age of weird effects you know that could
be
the sign of some massive profound shift
or could be
some [ __ ] up in the experiment or
you know yeah but i mean i think what he
said the most exciting phrase to hear is
is that's fun not not eureka but that's
funny because you know that is
ultimately those moments where you go oh
that's not what i expected that they can
be the ones that end up being really
profound if you're if you're lucky yeah
all these tensions and anxieties i say
what we really need is not a bigger
collider or telescope we need a
psychotherapist for the entire field and
that will help us get over our uh
incredible fears etc um so in kind of
the last segment i i wanted to uh to
discuss you know kind of the large
picture future um you know as we said
you know building a milky way galaxy
size collider is not not really
practical et cetera et cetera
i often wonder harry and i got your
impression about that if we're not
overlooking you know kind of the low
energy limit that that you know already
exists and you know if i had told you if
i told you know
i don't know weinberg
50 years ago you know and he wanted to
test things like this and he had his
dreams of a final theory which is one of
the books i got
upon graduation at case western reserve
university in that time and the ssc was
going to be built you know he speculates
about this this this future theory and i
if i had said to him look you know the
sac is going to be canceled don't worry
you know uh the higgs will be found um
but uh but you know would he despair
and then the second question would be
how would he react if i said look
stephen you're not going to get an ssc
that collides you know two protons
together at
nine nine nine nine nine nine nine you
know one thousand billionth of the speed
of light but you are going to get um a
collider that takes two 10 to the 56
uh nucleons
uh you know mass objects and collides
them together at you know one third the
speed of light you know could you can
you settle for that meaning you know
we're going to be doing uh you know
colliders of of of neutra pure neutronic
material
we don't even have to pay for the
neutrons they come for free uh you know
in other words like can we test the low
energy limit um of these things with
existing data or even upcoming data not
even looking at lisa or something like
that but ligo
um
you make this really fun point which is
true is that there's always a temptation
to upgrade your instrument uh so much so
that some people think you know just
never run the instrument just keep
upgrading it because when you win
by a factor of eight by doubling the
sensitivity in ligo it's pretty tempting
it's hard to get factors of almost an
order of magnet anyway long-winded
question but um looking back in your you
know former countrymen there at
cambridge uh sir isaac newton he proved
you know color unification if you will
of light by
you know two prisms and then he blocked
out you know the blue light and saw what
came out was not white light when he had
two prisms anyway
are we missing out on unification or
this obsession as i always call it are
we putting you know the toe the theory
of everything before the gut we don't
even have a grand unified theory correct
so um what can we do with existing data
or near future data like can we just
keep running lhcb and then our alice and
out will pop cool new results and and or
or can we look back in historical data
or cosmic data to do the same
yeah it's a good it's a really good
question actually i had this discussion
recently i was talking to a colleague at
imperial college who works on these
anomalies as well and i was sort of
asking him you know what does this make
you think he's the most senior
established academic about the future
you know does this does this get you
excited for the future collider for
example these anomalies because it's if
these anomalies are right then the
particles the forces that go with them
the particles are probably uh slightly
higher energy than the lhc although they
could be accessible at the lhc
potentially and he said well
i don't want to have to wait for the
future circular collider because i'm
going to be dead before this thing
delivers any data that's going to tell
us the uh so so basically and that's you
know i'm not that old yet but even
that's even sort of true i mean by the
time the fcc
tells us something about these anomalies
i will probably be retired um so if you
want to have a career where you find
something out you've got to look at what
data you've got available already and
there's a lot we can learn from the lhc
still so you know firstly we've got to
confirm these anomalies one way or
another i think that will probably
happen quite soon in the next few years
we'll get an answer and we can do that
by making different sorts of
measurements that the ones we've already
made with the existing data and i'm just
starting a new project which is going to
look back at the data we've got from
2012 2018 and extract new information
from it they're also with these much
larger data quantities that we're going
to have in the next decade we'll be able
to measure these places really precisely
we'll be able to infer lots of things
once if we rule these anomalies in and
they turn out to be real
there's a lot we can do
at low energy to figure out what the the
beast is i'm not i use this and this uh
analogy in the book which is you know
what we're sort of doing lhcb if you
think about it as like you're trying to
find a rare animal like an elephant say
in the jungle and you have this thick
dark jungle there's two two different
ways you can do it one is you go into
the jungle you wander around you see if
you bump into the elephant and that's
what it's sort of a direct what we call
a direct search it's what is what atlas
and cms do at the lhc they directly
produce new particles they detect them
they go aha there's the higgs there's
whatever
but actually there's another way of
doing it which is this indirect method
which is rather than going and looking
for the elephant which might be deep in
the jungle it might be really hard to
find it there might be one of them and
you're not very likely to stumble across
it if instead you look for evidence of
the elephant that leaves behind like
footprints on the ground broken branches
animal droppings whatever then you can
start to build a picture of this animal
without ever even seeing it and actually
there's if you go back to the history of
particle physics particularly
pretty much every particle since the
electron well it's not quite true but in
certain the last few decades every
particle that we've seen was really
discovered indirectly before it was seen
directly like there was evidence of the
zed boson 10 years before it was found
directly in a collider so really what
happens is these sort of indirect
experiments discover particles and then
colliders confirm them to some extent
and that so what lhcb can do with its
data
this this force if it's there will
modify loads of different it won't just
act in one area it will modify lots of
different processes in subtle ways and
by measuring all these different bits of
the forest floor effectively we can
start to build up a picture of what is
this animal like and that's the that's
the job that we've got in the next
decade or so so and at the same time
actually
as these anomalies are getting stronger
atlas and cms are kind of waking up to
the fact that this is actually quite
serious business and they are now
thinking very hard and starting to make
measurements looking for these forced
particles directly in the collisions in
because these particles are rather
unexpected they're not the sorts of
things that were the sort of vanilla new
physics options so a lot of the searches
that have already been done don't really
touch
the parameter space where these things
live so there's a lot you can do with
the direct search data as well so
there's a there's a very strong chance
we'll learn something we learn a lot in
the next decade without new machines it
may be that we get a very good picture
of what this thing looks like but we
don't find it directly and then that
will give us a really clear target so
we'll say okay we can tell from all
these measurements this thing probably
has an energy a massive
five tv or whatever and we're going to
need a collider with this sort of design
that collides these particles to produce
it and we can focus the next sort of the
future of the field in that sort of way
so i think yeah there's there's a lot
you can do at low energy and there's a
in you know even though i work at high
energy collider the energy scales of
beauty quarks is actually much lower
than the lhc you don't need an lhc to do
beauty physics and indeed there's um
there's an experiment in japan called
bell two which is currently taking data
on a much smaller electron positron ring
which basically is
specifically to make uh make beauty
quarks that's all it does and it studies
these things and that's another area we
may get some more information
that experiment is going to try to
corroborate what we're seeing at lhcb
and that will be the clincher i think
that will be the thing that really
convinces everyone if two independent
experiments see the same effect totally
different technology it's game over you
know this thing's this thing's real so
yeah there's a that's just in my area
and
this is true i think in you know dark
matter searches for example at colliders
where the the old sort of ideas about
wimps tended to be particular types of
particularly energy scales quite high
masses you know in the hundreds of gv or
tv
scale so far that's not shown up but
there's there's lots of models that say
well maybe dark matter lives at lower
masses than we thought which is hidden
in our current data sets we need to go
back and re-examine our assumptions
about the properties of these things so
yeah there's a lot you can do um a low
at lower energy although i'm still
talking really about the lhc which is
the highest energies we have but we
don't necessarily need to go to higher
energy to learn a lot more exactly yeah
although you know be careful with those
elephants because as jon von neumann
said you know with four parameters i can
fit an elephant and with five i can make
him wiggle his trunk
so
maybe that brings up the last topic
about you know the role of computation
in the the work that you do i mean most
you're not building you know the the
collider itself and much of the work has
been done and so a lot of the work does
come down to new advances in cpus gpus
and and so forth um you know we always
joke in in your field you get like our
year or lifetime of the experimental
data which might be a few petabytes uh
in cosmology you get that in in an hour
or two or a couple seconds maybe but you
throw away you know 99.999 you know kind
of the same ratio as you offer the speed
of light uh accelerating a proton um but
yeah you guys throw it away we keep it
um do you think we could get more out of
the existing data if we could make it
more efficient um would that rely on you
know improvements in computing or
storage uh something really simple i
mean quote unquote because as i
understand it you know most of the
advances in computing power immediately
gets sucked up by new clever uses of
those super computers so the moore's law
isn't really panning out as much could
there be advances with with uh you know
quantum error correction you know codes
or could there be a way to not have to
sacrifice so much of the data
and get to keep it so that you you know
don't have to build a bigger accelerator
you just use more of the events that
occur
yeah that's it's a really good question
and it's a problem that we grapple with
all the time so like actually i i was
grappling with this myself just last
week because this new data we're going
to get in in 2022
this trigger that i was writing to try
and select these rare decays what i
found was there's basically you know
you're allowed a certain amount of
bandwidth you're allowed a certain
amount of you know kilobits per second
that effectively that come out of the
experiment and you can't go over that
because you start to you know basically
everything will get overloaded and i was
finding i was having to put very harsh
requirements on the particles i was
looking for in order to keep the data
rate
within the allowed bandwidth and that
means you're throwing away a lot of
useful information
and
you know
at the moment it's quite hard to avoid
that because you've got lots of triggers
lots of people doing different things
with the same data so they all have to
fit within a budget and so on i mean
there's there's increasing interest i
mean one of the things that's this is
the big challenge really of lhcb in run
three is how do you
get this data rate out of the experiment
and the bottleneck really is you know
processing power and storage ultimately
and the more of that you can have the
more of the data you can record but you
know there are clever things you can do
and you know one of the things that's
happened a lot in the last 10 years you
know when we started out we were just
doing these very simple cut based
requirements more and more now it's
machine learning that's much more
efficient that can select the data
the signal much more efficiently and
reject the background much more
efficiently and in the future i think
you know one of the things that people
are working on is
actually although these things already
run in real time they kind of run on
what we call reconstructed information
so if you imagine a collision and
particles go everywhere and the first
thing that happens is uh the
reconstruction runs and it joins like
you have these dots in the detector
where a particle when it joins a line
through and it reconstructs trajectories
momentum energies all kinds of things so
there's quite high level information
that's fed into these algorithms that
already says there are 100 particles in
the event here's a list of their
momentum energies and their charges and
stuff like that but what we what would
be great is if you could have a machine
learning algorithm that doesn't have to
have that reconstruction it just looks
at the raw hits in the detector just the
unprocessed
digital information and can see patterns
in that directly and shortcut all of
that processing i mean maybe that's
something that's something i think that
is interesting and it's maybe where you
can make big gains in the future um
there's also the other problem as well
which is you know if you're throwing
away 99 of your data
you're doing that on the basis of things
you think you're going to see
so i'm you know if you're it's a
particularly acute at the other
experiments because you know we actually
do know we're looking for beauty quarks
mostly so we can we can predict what
they're like and that's fine but if
you're at some cms and you think okay
well i've got this model of dark matter
that i want to look for fine you can
write your algorithm to look for that
but what if dark matter is a bit
different to what you thought what if
it's a lower energies or it has
different lifetime or you know decays in
a different way than you expected you
might miss that completely
and so that that is another issue and
that's a harder problem to solve
but yeah for sure i mean
computing is more and more the limiting
factor for these experiments and more
much more than the hardware the detector
hardware itself and and both in terms of
data processing but also the other thing
we need a lot of the simulated data we
need to simulate the experiment to
calculate all kinds of systematic
effects and correct for efficiencies and
as you get more data you need more
simulation and that becomes a real
problem as well so so yeah it's it's a
it's a huge challenge and people working
very hard to address it people who know
a lot more about computers than i do i
should say
oh that's great well you know a lot
about a lot of things and therefore i
want to take advantage of your
very generous
discretionary time that's left that i
have uh you've been so generous but i
love to ask these existential questions
which i call the impossible thrilling
three so harry if you're willing to go
into the impossible uh please let me
know and we can begin that process right
now
yes i am willing
okay well you're a young man but um but
there is a concept of an ethical will
and an ethical will is in contra
distinction to your material will which
will uh hopefully not be activated
either one until you at least reach the
biblical age of 120 years old
but an ethical will uh and that's the
age moses
was before he failed to get into the
promised land and uh we all you know
have struggles with the promised land in
some sense and he left an ethical will
to the to the descendants the hebrews of
which i am one uh but also alfred nobel
left an ethical component of his will as
i said before he had to confer a benefit
to all mankind not just
have a
have a benefit you know to the scientist
who discovered the effect anyway i want
to ask you is there any piece of wisdom
ethical knowledge
that you would bequeath to your to your
biological but also your ideological
heirs when you spring forth this mortal
coil at the age of 120 if not later
god right ah that's a
interesting one i think
god there are so many i mean there's a
practical thing i think particularly
when i was earlier in my career i spent
a lot of time
worrying about the future and this
happens in academia particularly because
you have these like short-term insecure
contracts you never really know where
your next paycheck is coming from you
spend and and that that can be very i
think kind of um
it can be quite paralyzing some of the
time and i think one of the things i've
i've got better at as i've got older is
just chilling out about it and so it
comes from a sense of position a
privilege i guess that i kind of you
know you have all these things if i
don't get another contract what am i
going to do with my life you know i'm
going to end up on the street which of
course like you know for someone who's
sort of highly educated it's not really
a big risk actually you're always gonna
be okay maybe okay maybe you won't get
to do the exciting things that you were
doing before but things will be okay so
i think you know that that for me has
been quite an important lesson just to
kind of try and enjoy what you're doing
when you're doing it and not worry too
much about the future you know i think
that's a
a thing that i've at least i try to live
by that although i'm not always very
good at it because i think you know a
lot a lot of academics i think by nature
are quite anxious like worrying sorts of
people and if you go on you know
academic social media there's an endless
avalanche of negativity i think it's
quite it can be quite a depressing place
to be in europe which is very positive
and we'll have a link to that obviously
yeah um but you know i think that's
something you know appreciating what
you've got when you've got it and being
grateful for you know it's very easy i
think to take for granted the
opportunities you get and
you know i'm sure everyone has this i
actually when i worked the science
museum i remember arriving there and so
many people i met were just griping all
the time you know oh you know this is
we've been worked too hard we're not
getting paid enough et cetera and some
of those things are genuine complaints
but the other hand i did sort of think
you guys are mad like you're working at
one of the most amazing institutions in
the world and you basically get to play
for a living this is great and i think
that's also true
yeah yeah and that's also true of
science i think i think
well i i hope most people go into
science because they love it you don't
go into it generally i think to make
lots of money you know certainly not in
in the uk maybe more in the us than than
here but you know and if you don't love
what you do why are you doing it so i
think it's sort of a bit of gratitude
and appreciating the opportunities you
get and and that's a big lesson because
i think just makes life much more
livable
yeah i always uh i'm reminded there's a
youtuber in the uk named ali abdal and
he he was a physician and uh he went to
cambridge medical school it was tops in
his class etc and uh and then you know
he's become this youtube sensation with
millions and millions of followers
around the world and he makes you know
thousands of times more literally than
he made as a doctor in the uk and he
would ask his col colleagues when he was
struggling to see what he should do next
with his life he said you know if he won
the lottery and had a million pounds a
year or whatever
which is even less than he makes you
know would you stay a physician and uh
almost all of them said i would leave
that afternoon you know never come back
whereas a scientist you know you're
living proof of it i'm a public employee
in the state of california
you know we do it not for free but you
know it's not not as much as we could do
you know turning your your your skills
uh for evil and working for the
cyborg as i'm sure you could do okay
next question now we're going to go even
further into the future how are you
ready we're going to go a billion years
into the future with your uh late great
countrymen uh arthur c clarke had in the
sentinel uh which became 2001
a space odyssey in the movie by stanley
kubrick
and there's a scene with these primates
and they're they're they come upon this
this monolith this structure that has
all sorts of weird you know kind of
properties and it looks massive and they
try to hit it with a bone and
all sorts of things happen and later on
this shows up on the moon and we're not
really sure what it is it could be a
warning it could be a time capsule i'm
going to assume it's a time capsule and
ask you the following question
which is not unlike what richard feynman
once said it's called the cataclysm
question and his question was as follows
if in some cataclysm harry all
scientific knowledge were to be
destroyed and only one sentence passed
on to generations of creatures
what statement would contain the most
information in the fewest words
i don't know if you know what he said
the answer is but i am curious as to
what your answer would be to that very
question
well that is a very good question so
obviously feynman says that everything
is made of atoms that's his bit of
knowledge and i it's hard to beat that
really i mean i'm trying i'm trying to
think of something different to say
maybe it would be the scientific method
it would be you know we can learn about
the world by making hypotheses testing
them see if the evidence supports the
the hypothesis or not i think that
because you know you go back to the
history of well it's not even a history
of science a history of thought and that
idea is not you know not around until
relatively recently this idea of making
observations rather than just kind of
having prejudices or beliefs about the
world without which is which are not
really supported by any kind of rigorous
process of testing i think that that in
itself if you were to follow that kind
of process in any area will allow you
quite quickly to make discoveries and
maybe if we'd figured that out a bit
sooner we don't you know discover things
more quickly so maybe that's an
alternative
answer to the question good thing you
didn't put you know i'd put on a cd-rom
you know with uh uh some sounds of
nature or something i actually asked
andrew and uh the late where the widow
of the late great carl sagan who's uh uh
how to make an apple pie from scratch uh
segment of cosmos inspired your
wonderful book
and and she said uh uh something from
the book of mika which is to act justly
love mercy and uh and but not walk
humbly with your god which is the end of
the mika quote because she's an atheist
uh and i thought that was kind of cute
okay last question harry before we break
and give you some time off on a
christmas season uh christmas eve eve
eve uh there in the in an evening in the
uk uh the last question now is we're
gonna go backwards in time my friend and
we're gonna go back utilizing sir arthur
c clarke's so-called third law which
states the only way of discovering the
limits of the possible is to go beyond
them into the impossible and that's the
origin and the name of my podcast i
don't ask you harry accordingly uh in
your life what sort of mysterious aspect
of life perplexed you as a as a 20 year
old and
and yet the current version of yourself
would give advice to
surpass go beyond have the courage to go
into the impossible so i'm asking you
advice to your 20 year old self
who
god i don't know if i'm any wiser 15
years later
which is a bit of a depressing thought
god what would i say that's a that's a
very good question i think
i mean one of the things that missed i
think a truck both beguiled me and
excited me but also sort of missed i
found mysterious when i was sort of when
you're when you're 20 you're in your
middle of your undergraduate you're
learning about you know physics and it
you have this amazing experience it's
sort of like you get the greatest hits
of human thought all compressed into the
space of a few years and
it's this really exciting story and i
think what i kind of came away from it
is you know with it was the the fact
that we you we can learn we have been
able to learn
so much about the world that it is it
appears to be explicable and the you
know mathematical law describes the way
that the universe ticks and i think that
is a a very very mysterious thing but
i'm not sure it's anything i have any
greater insight into now
but i mean
in terms of sort of i must like one year
old though you're a very wise 20 year
old well i don't know about that i don't
know about that um but i mean
yeah i guess
it's sort of you know about this pursuit
of curiosity i think i think that's the
sort of thing i would encourage myself
to not lose sight of because i think
there's you know
there's times where you kind of go
through your career where you kind of
feel a bit disillusioned and i think you
know actually continuing to ask
questions and be interested in the world
around you is really important and
pushing you forward so i think i think
that's maybe that's a bit of advice i'd
pass on but i don't really know whether
i have had any great profound insights
maybe ask me again in
30 years or something
i hope you'll come back before then
harry uh and maybe even get together in
person someday and share a pint and a
slice of delicious apple pie your recipe
uh it stops still in the um electro week
phase transition portion of the recipe
but as the very first cookbook author to
come on the into the impossible podcast
i want to thank you for your generosity
of spirit your time
your writing your communication your
science and your inspiration hopefully
there'll be a
young lad or lass out there who will
find this book at just the right moment
and uh go in and and even surpass you as
you say in the book and and i often say
our job is to make ourselves obsolete so
harry where can people find you and uh
and find your wonderful book
well you can find me i've got a website
which is harrycliff.co.uk
if you just search for harry cliff
you'll find it i'm on twitter at harry v
cliff which i
occasionally tweet things i haven't been
so good recently i also have my doorbell
and you can also uh the book you can
find in all good book shops so if you
search for how to make apple pie from
scratch you'll find it it was a real
pleasure talking to you brian thank you
so much thank you so much harry happy
holidays thank you too any sufficiently
advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
do
[Music]
you